politique en france jean-marie cavada
lâche françois bayrou s'est confirmé
l'ancien journaliste accepte de diriger
une liste ump aux élections municipales
à paris dans le 12ème arrondissement
commentaire du président du modem cela
ne grandit pas la politique
diaby imbert virginie travers plus de 40
message sur son téléphone portable des
encouragements pour la plupart affirme
jean-marie cavada arno avec françois
bayrou hier soir ce fut une conversation
en direct pour consommé la rupture
françois est quelqu'un qui a besoin de
chaleur et d'amitié est à la fois c'est
quelqu'un qui ne peut pas se départir
d'une solitude absolue dans laquelle il
s'enfermera de plus en plus et pour
celui qui s'en va aujourd'hui le modem
n'a pas tenu ses promesses
notre contrat était de former une équipe
mais une équipe qui a des
responsabilités pas une équipe qui saute
un club des applaudissements françois
bayrou critiqué françois bayrou déserté
tout cela n'est que prétexte pour le
leader centriste cette ultime défection
a pour lui des raisons très prosaïque
tout le monde sait bien que
des intérêts personnels et que souci de
carrière et intérêts personnels c'est
pas ce qu'ils devraient faire vivre oui
mais jean marie cavada c'était un peu la
dernière cette affiche du modem en
quelques mois françois bayrou aura perdu
presque tous ses lieutenants hervé morin
devenu ministre de la défense le député
maurice leroy avec sa cravate orange la
couleur de la campagne de françois
bayrou cela en fondé le nouveau centre
andré santini lui avait rejoint nicolas
sarkozy dès le mois de février
aujourd'hui françois bayrou n'a plus que
trois députés avec lui à l'assemblée
donc un financement largement revu à la
baisse avant son congrès ce week-end il
préfère se rappeler que sept millions de
français avaient voté pour lui à la
présidentielle